all right as a cloud of corruption looms
over the Biden campaign while hunter
Biden is trying to salvage his father's
career as he is found at the center of
these issues of cronyism remember that
ABC interview that he did that aired
yesterday well guess what during his
attempted attempt at damage control
Hunter took a weak shot at the
president's son Don junior who's here to
respond but let's take a look first I've
been through some real real stuff this
isn't real stuff it isn't it truly isn't
that part of it that Barnum and Bailey
you know say anything do anything you
want you know I mean like you know
Donald Prince Humperdinck Trump jr. is
not somebody that I really care about
here with reaction author of the
upcoming book triggered how the left
thrives on hate and wants to silence us
is the executive vice president of the
Trump Organization president's son
Donald Trump jr. I think you're the son
that's most like the father by the way I
appreciate that
yeah maybe it took 41 years to get there
but I guess hunter Biden has some of
that from Joe he also mumbles through
all of his interviews so I'm gonna let
you go I want you to respond fully but
here's my take on this he is dumb he
admitted everything we knew he admitted
no experience Ukraine China
no experience energy oil gas no
experience private equity we're talking
about a ton of he lot even mislead when
he said ID not a penny we know he's got
equity of course we probably 20 minutes
here's the thing if this was you and
your vice president dad sorry to your
dad about the demotion it would be
never-ending coverage end of the world
Sean no and that's the real and by the
way it's not just then how about right
out of school he gets a high paying job
from MBA the biggest bank and the
largest employer in the state of
Delaware where daddy is conveniently a
senator he then gets on the board of
Amtrak I believe that was 1996 so he was
what about 27 what was his experience I
guess dad took the train once in a while
so that made him qualified to do that
you know it never ends then you had the
China you have Ukraine mine a problem
he's never been in energy hmm doesn't
speak Ukrainian minor details but it's
okay
and by the way more importantly than
that they want to question my family
aren't imagine being in hiding for
months like he's been since we've been
talking about this and you come out and
that's the interview give that's just
guilt in and of itself because it was a
attempt he wouldn't have gotten the
millions brought for his father he said
it on the stage then Joe denies it later
on and of course Anderson Cooper doesn't
call him I despite the fact that CNN
even CNN fake news fact check them and
said well hunter contradicted this so
you know it was pretty disgusting and I
like you said if Donald Trump jr. took
1.5 dollars from China not 1.5 billion
showing just 1.5 dollars
we'd solve the fake news media problem
because their heads would explode and
there would be none of them left it
would be over if I did that for a
no-show job for eighty three thousand
dollars a month in the Ukraine no
problem you know what the difference
between the Biden's and us are we were
international business people before
politics and we gave up doing all new
deals going forward we didn't become
magically international business people
because of our political position even
we put that over aside for years really
a brother had to give up raising money
for cancer it's it's insane the double
standard is despicable
they utilize that platform with a wink
wink nod not you know Joe Biden knows
nothing about it other than hunter says
he does and there's pictures of them
playing golf together right but he knows
nothing about it
Joe Biden willing to fire the prosecutor
by threatening the Ukrainian government
with millions of dollars in aid if they
don't get rid of the guy investigating
his son a billion
give me a break Sean it never ends and
the fact that they're out there
pretending like this wasn't you know hey
I'm not gonna say that I am not part of
what who I am because of my father that
would be foolish
okay but the difference is we did it as
capitalists we did it as businesspeople
we didn't do it pretending and under the
cloak of chose this great public servant
well here son here's every
you've ever had and now they do the
family's off-limits
kids are off-limits hunter Biden's fifty
okay I wasn't off-limits when it started
at 38 Hunter Biden shouldn't be
off-limits now
bearer was 10 Baran was 10 they had no
problem trying to go after him they've
made comments about my children as young
as four at the time when they started
making those comments until my little
Khloe you know the double standard is
despicable
hey the difference between us and them
when there's a question we put it out
there when they say hey what about this
I put my emails out there when my father
did it here's the transcript how come
they're doing all over there's things
under the cloak of secrecy everything
Adams hips have seen it no one else has
seen it I'm still hearing about that
from Russia he's seen evidence but they
won't be colluding with a Russian he
thinks as a Russia is in Russian what do
they have to hide why can't they do it
in front of the American people like
we've been doing it it's insane and it's
not fair here's what Americans see it
Sean when you don't have any experience
which he admitted mm-hm and you're
getting paid all this money you're
admitting because your dad's the vice
president thing is why would they give
all this money to the son China and
Ukraine except that they're really
buying favor with the father of course
that clear of course they are and when
you're the father and your son's entire
career is dependent on that they own you
Sean that's what it is they've bought
Biden ink and they've been doing it both
domestically whether it was MBNA Bank
whether it was Amtrak whatever it was
domestically when he was a senator and
had influence over domestic policy and
they started doing it internationally
the second Joe Biden became vice
president and had authority abroad I
want to know here all this is going on
with your dad the Democrats are in
disarray they've done nothing for three
years that remotely looks like helping
with peace prosperity safety and
security then you got these radical 20
20 Democrats that are talking about 94
trillion in 10 years 36 trillion in 10
years
I don't see this working for them I see
that your father's supporters will be
stronger
then 2060 I think without question
because honestly people even in the
middle they see the insanity the other
side doesn't talk about issues they
don't talk about unprecedented
unemployment numbers for every
demographic in the country they
certainly don't talk about six point
three million people removed off of the
Food Stamp rolls because guess what so
those are the million those are people
no longer dependent on government and
that's a real problem for the Democrats
if Nancy Pelosi maybe would act on the
u.s. MCA you know the deal that they
said no one could ever renegotiate
failed NAFTA my father did it but they
won't vote on it why it's good for the
American people why won't they bring it
up because they need impeachment they
can't beat him at the ballot box and of
course they got to continue the hoax so
a lot of people ask me when you're
running what year do you think I'm not
right now honestly my only for American
cuz you as a father is to get my father
reelected for 2020 because he's doing an
incredible job and by the way he's doing
an incredible job despite unprecedented
in from John this has never happened to
an American president it's disgusting
it's a disgrace to our republic in our
democracy and it should never be allowed
to happen again and the only cure for
that trump derangement syndrome is four
more years that's why I'm spending my
time traveling all over the country
campaigning for him campaigning for
those in Congress and in the Senate and
in governor seats who believe in him
because we can do this and we can get
this country on the right track again
okay our issues shouldn't be how many of
the 97 genders are we discussing today
we have real problems in this country
and we have to address that the
Democrats refused to do so and we have
to hold them to task Donald Trump jr.
we'll see when your book comes out thank
you thank you appreciate it